في الاثناء قال اولكسندر تارنافيسكي قائد
قوات منطقه تافاريا جنوب شرق اوكرانيا ان
قواته نفذت اكثر من 1400 ضربه مدفعيه
وصاروخيه وكبدت سبع سرايا في الجيش الروسي
خسائر بين قتيل وجريح في منطقه تارا سيفكا
جنوب شرقي زبروجيا واعلن تارنافيسكي عن
تدمير اثنتين وسبعين وحده من المعدات
العسكريه الروسيه بينها 19 دبابه وثلاثه
مستودعات للذخيره
من جهته قال المتحدث باسم قياده عمليات
شرق اوكرانيا ان قواتهم تقدمت نحو كيلومتر
ونصف الكيلومتر باتجاه منطقه باخموت من
اتجاهات المختلفه مستغله عمليات تبديل
القوات الروسيه هناك جنوبا اعلن قائد
عمليات منطقه تاغاريا جنوب شرق اوكرانيا
تنفيذ قواتهم لهجمات وانها الحقت خسائر
باربع وحدات عسكريه روسيه في محور زبروشيا
استغل حركه تناوب وحدات العدو ونشن هجمات
مضاده تواصل قواتنا تحقيق النجاح في اتجاه
ضخمه حيث تقدمنا خلال النهار 2400 متر في
مناطق مختلفه كما قصف العدو مواقعنا باكثر
من ثلاثمائه قذيفه مدفعيه وثماني غارات
جويه اشتبكنا مع العدو 6 مرات قتلنا
خلالها
138 جنديا منهم واصبنا 236
واسرنا جنديا واحدا